[Music]
all right boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Alan
Saki on very excited to be talking about
who gets what and why what's the future
and why it's up to us and so much more
we have coined the Oracle of Silicon
Valley joining us Tim O'Reilly hello hi
how are you thanks for that introduction
thanks for coming on to the show Tim
O'Reilly is so awesome we're so grateful
to have you here Tim O'Reilly been 40
years in Silicon Valley doing all
different types of work with O'Reilly
Media his company everything from
conference producing to book publishing
investing wrestling with the hardest
questions who gets what and why what's
the future why it's up to us I'm so
grateful that you came on to our show
thank you Tim well thanks for having me
now I should say that this phrase that
I've been using a lot in my talks lately
who gets what and why there's actually
the title of someone else's book al Roth
who won a Nobel Prize in Economics for
market design is is really somebody
who's given me a tool and I think of
ideas as tools for thinking there's
really helped shape the way that I'm
looking at our current world in which we
used to think that there was this free
market that helped determine who gets
what and why but we've increasingly
moved into a world where there are
algorithms designed by companies that
are shaping the choices we make and
really the design of markets is this new
field you know because when we people
talk about the market as if it's one
thing but in fact we are now in markets
that are shaped and designed by for
example people at Facebook people at
Google
by Wall Street and in fact many of the
great political battles are battles to
shape the rules of markets and those
markets are fundamentally mechanisms for
allocation and what Al's work did that
so important was he demonstrated that
you can actually intervene in markets
and make them work better so he got a
surprise for working on markets where
money is not a factor so kidney
transplant market places you know I mean
if you you know it's pretty hard you
have to get a person who needs one a
person who has one to give at the same
time they have to have matching blood
types as all these complicated factors
and he said well if we can increase
trust in the market that I can give you
a kidney today and I'll get one for the
person that I love who I'm not a match
for later you know you can actually
create longer chains you know so you
know here was a he looked at a bunch of
mechanisms for how do you change the
trust dynamics in this you know pretty
major thing that people would do in
their lives that has you know literally
life-changing benefits he also looked at
things like college admissions law
clerks matching up with judges and you
know how these markets can go awry and
so in my book one of the things that I
tried to look at was the evolution of
algorithmic marketplaces and I've
continued to think about that since I
published it and here you can kind of
see when they go right how they could be
this incredibly powerful tool that helps
us manage things that enormous scale and
speed you think about Google you know
literally having a search across
trillions of webpages
and find you know more or less what we
want you think about Amazon where
they've got 600 million products skews
you know this is a store of an
unbelievable scale you could not do it
we can also see how it goes wrong you
know Facebook was like hey we'll just
show people more of what they respond to
and get engaged with and that went badly
wrong it was gamma ball and so clearly
as a market design for
which they're wrestling with today and
of course in my book I kind of go
through that sequence and then I try to
make the case and yes our economy is
also one of those today one of those
vast algorithmic systems with designers
and with rules that may not be the best
rules and that can go wrong and and make
the allocations that seem well they're
just the market that's just the way the
market works and what we have to
understand is the market is a human
artifact designed with rules that favor
some people over others and the whole
game of politics is around shaping those
power dynamics and those rules and so
ultimately I guess a lot of it I've
gotten obsessed with over the last we
have five six years is taking the
lessons that I've learned in my career
in technology and saying oh how are they
playing out today in our society okay
Tim as you can obviously tell has such a
wealth of knowledge that he's going just
giving us this massive picture and I
love it and I want to try and dive into
this through Tim's eyes tim has been
here from the dot even pre dot-com days
yeah doing book publishing they have
things like this open catalog of all of
the World Wide Web
all the way to you know doing the
dot-com doing web 2.0 doing the mobile
social doing the the open source
movement actually proliferating that as
a common phrase around the world and
inspiring people with that now going
through this transition with with
Internet of Things and with data and
being right here at a cutting edge is
again teaching it to people around the
world and so not only have you been here
doing that for 40 years but now you're
painting out this really beautiful
picture which you write about in your
book I highly highly recommend reading
what's the future please please check
that out the links in the bio read it
read it read it share it with people and
let's let's unpack this now you see you
gave us a couple thoughts here
one of them is this algorithms so
algorithms let's say 40 years ago were
much less involved in the way that we
see information in the way that it
influences political elections all this
type of stuff and now the couple
handfuls of people that control the way
that two billion human animals see what
happens on YouTube or what happens on
any of 10-cents platforms or across the
world this is becoming more and more of
a do we come in with a regulation as you
said are there ways to come in with
regulations that make the markets better
and that's a very interesting point that
I think you know will it will end up
getting to but I think the most
important principle here is that there
has been a tremendous amount over the
last 40 years of wealth concentration
that has occurred for the benefit of the
one-percenters and what meanwhile the
median income people and the low SES
people have had a stagnation where me
and a lot of the other Millennials and
Gen Z as you're very familiar with with
children have what do we have we have a
life outcome that is projected to be
worse than our parents and this is Inc
and that and this may be supplemented by
things like having a new strategy of
capitalism 2.0 when that does think
slightly differently and so this is
where this conversation comes into play
what is the sure sure yeah yeah well I
think the key part of the title actually
came from my wife Jen pahlka who's the
founder of a nonprofit called Code for
America and I said well the book will be
called WTF what's the future and she
said oh should be what's the future and
why it's up to us because that idea that
the future is something that we shape is
is very central in fact it that that you
know it is a designed thing now again
there's a lot of contingencies and a lot
that can surprise us but so many parts
of it are shaped by decisions that
humans make
and so the idea that we have to
understand better what are some of the
dynamics that you talk about and make
better choices I think is central to my
thinking so let me just expand a little
bit on this idea of inequality by kind
of going back to the notion of
algorithmic systems and what we learn
from Google and Facebook and other
systems and that is that these systems
typically have what you call an
optimization function often referred to
as an objective function in the book I
actually refer to it as the Fitness
function because of it gives you a neat
tie to a field of evolutionary biology
just idea Fitness landscape but this
this thing that you're trying to
optimize for and of course what Fitness
landscapes remind us of is that you can
have a fitness peak that is not actually
the highest peak and you can only get
off of that peak by going down into the
valley to get up to another peak so
that's why history often has these peaks
and valleys because you can't get to the
you can see this better future but you
can't get there simply by continuing up
and to the right which is why the
Silicon Valley you know millennial
fantasy of the singularity I think is so
wrong is that yeah it smooths out all
the curves you know and it's not let's
not how it actually happens yes even if
you believe that there is long term
progress there can be steep valleys in
between the next increment of progress
they see like to say to Ray Kurzweil you
do know that the aya Sophia and Istanbul
was the largest building in the world
for you know for a thousand years you
know that's a long time to have a body
of knowledge to lose it and then to only
slowly gain it back and so I think that
we we you know I'm sorry I'm backing a
little bit so this optimization function
you know when we look at this you know
all this whirring of
the 1% wealth inequality that was
something we designed into our economy
starting in about the late 70s early 80s
because if I look in my book I'm not
really only an amateur historian but I
look at some economic turning points and
if you look at this we had in the 20s
you know we had this so also this
massive inequality which eventually led
to a Great Depression you know we were
World War Great Depression things got
pretty bad and in particular they made a
set of choices after the first world war
which was you know that Victor has
punished the losers
they did not treat the returning
veterans well and so then you have this
wonderful example after World War two
where the US in particular made better
choices they basically said Oh wrong
idea
you know we're not going to punish the
losers we're gonna build them up you
know you have the Marshall Plan you have
you know really the rebuilding of Europe
not just the rebuilding of our allies
the rebuilding of our former enemies and
you also have this you know basically
embrace as the fundamental optimization
function of the economy full employment
you had you know things like the GI Bill
you had you know money you know
returning veterans we got to get them
either
to go to school start a business you
know we buy a house you know we the
government had this intervention and the
really the objective function of the
economy was full employment because they
remembered what happened after the first
world war and then you know as often
happens you know you have an objective
function and it runs its course it does
the thing that it was trying to do and
people just don't adapt fast enough you
know the roads kind of winding and they
keep going in the straight line so then
we said well this has led to inflation
you know we have this big problem we
need to actually have the a different
objective function they picked one which
was corporate profits and guess what it
actually did make the economy better for
a while it cracked the back of inflation
things were pretty good for a while
but then it ran its course it was like
holy cow you know this is like this you
know and they already value humans
that's right we're and now we're kind of
in coming up for a you know way too late
for a big re-evaluation so in my book I
kind of make you know the analogy and
again I'm kind of going back and forth
between these technological systems that
we're dealing with and what I've learned
from them and then you know looking at
things like the economy but across both
of them you have this wonderful
mythology that matches both of those
patterns and that is you know the story
of genies from Arabian mythology you
know you ant you get three wishes you
know you always know they go wrong right
you ask for something it's what you
think you want but what you get is what
you asked for
not what you actually wanted and you
know like Facebook is such a great
example of that and it's such a way to
see oh yeah
we can design a system with the best of
intentions and again you know maybe you
know people a lot of people like to rag
on Facebook and go they were really a
bad actor for I think they were you know
I've spent a lot of time with Mark and I
think they were really trying to do
something good and interesting and it
went wrong and here's the thing that I
would say is that's so important now
everybody's beaten on Facebook and I go
there actually pivoting faster in
responsib we would we screwed up they're
trying really hard for a company that
size yeah you compare that to fossil
fuel companies going you know an auto
companies oh we screwed up you know it's
like no we're we're you know 50 60 70
years denial phase
tobacco companies denial phase pharma
companies denial phase you know it's
like you know tech for all that it's
screwed up on is actually way more
responsive and going whoa we got to
really try to fix this they haven't
succeeded yet but you know I look around
these companies they're all trying yet
there's a public appearances about it
but it's not as public appearances
they're deeply committed and they're
trying new technological architectures
they're changing their business models
you know there's not a way from the
tension economy no no not yet entirely
but there
they're working at you know and you know
employees are working out not for better
wages but to actually for a better moral
stance about what their company works on
yes it is a I think if the rest of our
society were as responsive you know to
the some of the challenges we face
you know we'd see Wall Street banks
going whoa we and again do you see
people starting to talk about it you
know where tech iterates faster than the
fossil fuel industry asar than tobacco
Big Pharma yeah starting to you know
people saying hey we really have to take
this social responsibility seriously
you know we're screwing up you know we
are starting to see that move but I
think we have to put all in this broader
context that yes the choices we make in
our businesses the choices we make in
society could be different yeah that's
the heart of what the big lesson I get
from taking from tech is yeah this is a
design system and a better design can
have better outcomes and and we have to
learn from what we did wrong as quickly
as possible and keep pivoting yes so
let's talk about that code because this
is kind of what you know what we're what
we're talking about is civilization's
code we're talking about the way that
we've designed the way that we engage
with each other that we engage with the
products and services that run Jerrold
all that kind of stuff and the the
conversation that we were having earlier
that I want us to circle back to is this
big history perspective on society that
we went to two hundred thousand years to
get a billion people then it took 200
years to get seven billion more Piell
then the exponential technology has all
hockey-stick up at Moore's law and every
single genomic response in every every
single way that there's now permeating
every every field it's adding these
layers of complexity to our world that
we didn't prepare for worse I'm kind of
our code hasn't caught up right and so
now it's up to us to determine what is
capitalism 2.0 scone
what is the code of potentially adding
regulation to some of the algorithmic
bureaucracies that are occurring to make
it more equitable what are the lines of
code that need to be added to wealth
inequality yeah to make it better for
uplifting all humans into the next yeah
iterations so this is what I kind of
like to hear your daughter on the new
code alright well I guess the first
thing I would say is the new code is the
old code you know in some sets I think
we've always known what our objective
ought to be you know we've been working
on it back since the first legal code
code that's recorded the code of
hammurabi you know we're we're kind of
trying to figure out what does it mean
to be good to each other what does it
mean to be fair yeah and so you know
we're in some sense we keep you know I I
think with sometimes with quotes I keep
thinking this wonderful live from
Wallace Stevens or the poet he says we
keep coming back and back to the rail
you know we keep coming back and back to
this fundamental thing that we are you
know civilization progresses when we
take care of each other I mean you know
the the primitive you know impulse of
other is enemy is you know something
we've been working you know through
millennia to get better and in fact you
know you've all know Harare does a
fabulous job in sapiens of retelling the
history of humanity through the the the
story of what are the mechanisms for
trust at greater and greater scale yeah
you know and it's actually a lot of it
is as he comes back to his storytelling
you know it's a how do we create and of
course this is something I've actually
loved for years because this was my
favorite poet Wallace Stevens actually
talked about that yeah he had a
wonderful idea that we were searching
for the supreme fiction you know that
effectively is were aesthetic visions
that shaped you know our relationship
with each other and we were trying to
sell each other on
on the future and so I but Harare really
captured it beautifully in that history
of humanity and I think we are now
looking for what story will actually
help seven or eight nine billion people
to survive together yes no because it's
not just our tribe you know you know
it's not just you know here are the
pieces as my colleague you call it the
jigsaw yeah it's like a jigsaw puzzle on
the table and we're trying to see the
pattern I've been trying to figure out
how to arrange them into a story yeah
bind together humanity under the unity
well and I think that the you know the
pieces haven't all arrived but here's
what I see that's that's really powerful
one we have an economy that's clearly
off the rails in a variety of ways and
one is this this axis of inequality but
probably a even bigger one is the axis
of you know climate change and the risks
that come with that and we're slowly
waking up to that and you know we're
just gonna have to change the way we do
things more sustainably
but there's another so I think about the
future as a set of vectors you know and
a vector of course is a direction plus a
quantity right and some of the vectors
are pushing harder or faster and some
you know and they're coming in different
directions but they sum up into the
future and so so it's okay so we're
running into the endgame of a certain
kind of consumer culture because you
know as we have you know more and more
people wanting to have a lifestyle
equivalent to what the you know the West
has had you know we're not just sort of
going from you know a couple of billion
people to nine billion people or
whatever or whatever that we're gonna
peak at we're also going to nine billion
people who all want to use a hundred
times as many resources so it's as if we
had gone to 90 billion and clearly you
know there's a lot of things that we go
hey is this really the best way to do it
that basically our economy should run on
making more and more stuff and
encouraging people to
throw it away no and and the you know
because companies have to keep growing
their their rule is keep growing and
that and making more money you know it's
like this this machine that's running
you know faster and faster and faster
and for what you know are we actually
happier you know if you say no we're
actually trying to optimize for human
happiness and human happiness is
actually maybe in fact so anyway so is
that vacuum this amazing factor which is
that one of the reasons that money took
on such a powerful role in our society
is it is in fact one of those shared
methodologies that enables trust it's
functional it's it's it's this powerful
way to get people to cooperate and for a
long time this idea in the market was
that effectively price signaling was in
fact the guiding factor of the invisible
hand you know people say well how much
will you pay for this and depending on
how much supply there is the price you
know goes down or up you know supply and
demand equalize at some magical crossing
point that's the the the market price
and so on and yet here is starting to be
evidence amazing evidence that we can
run incredibly efficient markets without
money and what are the ones that I like
to point people to is Google make oh
wait a minute
kugel makes tons of money right but if
you look at it
their primary market is matching people
up with the information they know
they're looking for and they use
hundreds of factors of big data and
algorithmic systems an AI to say oh this
is what you're really looking for right
not one of those factors is money
they separated out money into a separate
marketplace of advertising which uh
which was effectively for a long time
was really just an absolute sidecar it
literally was the sidebar you know down
down the side yeah now I think they've
really changed that and I think they've
kind of lost the plot because this was
the genius that
actually had a market that was not
dominated by money
this was the breakthrough and I think
Amazon same thing back when I first
started with autumn or style yeah well
yeah well open-source is sort of another
example of this but yeah like you know
back when I was first working on web 2.0
and the idea of collective intelligence
I used to contrast amazon.com which of
that point was just a bookseller online
bookseller with Barnes & Noble I said
look here's Barnes and Noble
you know when I do a search look what I
find the first thing I find is the stuff
that they've gotten people to advertise
for you know so when I go to Amazon you
know I used to use my JavaScript book as
an example which was widely regarded
this is the best book on JavaScript
David Flanagan this JavaScript the
definitive guide and it came up first on
Amazon he had the most reviews had the
most positive reviews it wasn't the
cheapest you know but it was the one
that everybody said this is the best and
that's what Amazon showed you as the
first result of the search and you know
Barnes and Noble was like well here's
some book that some publisher paid his
Cobb for and I said this is why Amazon
is gonna win now look at how Amazon is
losing the plot the fastest part of the
growing part of their business today is
their advertising business and now when
you go to Amazon you no longer see the
best product up front there they are
trying to promote stuff that advantages
them and so again part of what I try to
do in my book was to kind of talk about
some of these principles and say look
when companies forget these things that
actually give them advantage you know
they tend to lose out over time and I
think we're really and this is a baby
maybe my next book is really about
algorithmic monopolies and how they go
wrong because I think both Google and
Amazon are starting to go down the
slippery slope of losing what made them
great and forgetting that they were
actually in service of the of they were
a matching marketplace that really was
in service of making the best match and
they moved away from that to being an
algorithmic marketplace that makes them
the match that makes them the most money
so they've kind of they're they're
losing their place and
an exemplar but that being said they
still show us this ability with massive
amounts of data to build better
marketplaces and to build better systems
that decide who gets what and why and
there's some great examples in the
environmental space Karla Gomez has
something called the Institute that
Cornell has something I think it's
Cornell somebody do something called the
Institute for computational
sustainability and they take a lot more
factors into account they work with it
she was doing some work with the
Brazilian Power Company it's like okay
let's look at your power requirements
the cost of building dams you know on
these various tributaries of the Amazon
how many people you're going to displace
what the ecological impact let's take
more factors into account and they were
end up just like Google using these 200
factors were able to make better
recommendations than the old things that
said well just show them what whatever
people are willing to pay the highest
price for all right taking Albany they
take all the factors into account they
were actually getting better economic
results as well
totally same thing they did another
project or people that she was
associated with the project where they
were timing a release of water for the
California rice farmers to the time when
the migrating birds were coming through
and it worked out better for both the
farmers too they eat the pests so
there's all these cool pieces of work
where I think we are now for the first
time building tools that allow us to
actually invent a new economy and it's
not that it's capitalism 2.0 it's
something profoundly different it's
simply a different way of organizing the
code of civilization the code of
civilization yes yeah so I think the
whatever we end up calling it whatever
it ends up being I like thinking about
it as an update in CODIS now we've been
yeah for instance several times and
throughout what we you know you're look
segments of what you just unpacked what
continues to come to mind is where we
agree on our making this new map yeah
this new way to help people see the
world right and and I think one of the
central principles of it is when when
society evolved so quickly and you just
see populations Jam skyrocket an
exponential technology skyrocket and
institutions and humans aren't able to
keep up the way that they're valued in
the labor markets and everything that
you just see so many oops moments happen
at once and when we walk down our
beautiful city of San Francisco and we
see such a staggering dichotomy between
the haves and the have-nots right on our
primary Street Market Street that you
see that this is about the seeds the
rotten seeds that haven't gotten the
nutrients they need because now social
fabric wasn't programmed to help make
sure that those nutrients didn't have
trauma that they had the loving caring
mother and father and their real in
their family and their upbringing that
they had the food and water and shelter
and necessities that they needed to have
it that that we went up so fast our
social fabric wasn't able to make sure
that the seeds didn't have you know that
didn't that they didn't get run and that
they had the right nutrients and so this
is kind of this reoccurring theme is
that when you have this blitzscaling
model this model of the hair versus the
model of the tortoise the slow down and
think maybe we have a hundred million
humans on the planet and we decide that
a thousand years ago that we slow down
and we think how do we make sure that
every single one of these Minds gets to
their maximal creative flourishing that
we build trust in the way geopolitically
that we build trust and we cooperate so
that we don't have the tens of millions
of people that die in there 100 million
plus Alan I don't know we'll stand why
why you don't acknowledge that these
people that are in trauma these people
that are set up to be in compromising
situations all the problems that we have
among us I don't understand why you
don't acknowledge that that's also part
of the
capitalistic system you know in order to
if you have private prisons you need to
create the criminal I just want to
acknowledge that Alan you know you you
you you talk like you know we have to
fix something it's it's not broke
there's a reason for it right yeah yeah
yeah absolutely right we not will so now
Ron you're indicating what the current
system exists today and how its
structured and that is correct
at the same time we're discussing what
looking back and thinking about how to
act as a tortoise and slow down and
think as society evolves can prevent
things like that from happening and that
is one of one of the reasons the shows
called simulation yes because you have
to be able to think abstractly about how
society could have evolved to be a more
beautiful place that enabled all these
seeds to flourish at their fullest
potential
I would just say we can only live life
forwards and so we have to go forward
from where we are and I guess not
experiments important yeah no I hear
that but yeah let me just say a couple
things one I think first of all we have
to be able to think in scenarios and
possibilities thought experiments is
exactly right so I want to give you two
and one is John Maynard Keynes you know
economic possibilities for our
grandchildren written really it the you
know as the Great Depression was
unfolding where he said this is a
temporary hiccup you know we have the
means you know through you know human
ingenuity to make everybody prosperous
right and that is in fact I think is in
the realm of possibility and there are
things that we need to debug in our
system that are causing that not to work
but I also think that there is and that
often gets paired with this idea that
somehow we have to slow down that we
have to
you know have a very different kind of
society and I think that may not be
necessarily you know the back to the
land I mean you know one of my all-time
favorite books is a utopian novel from
there was written in the 30s called
Islandia and it's about a land with a
slower lifestyle and I've lived in the
country I have a lot of friends who kind
of you know went back to the land during
that you know the 70s and so on so just
a closer connection to earth but but
yeah maybe but I also just want to hold
out something else and that's something
that Jeff Bezos said recently which I
really thought was good and I argue with
my sort of more hippie friends Fatih he
wishes he was defending why he thinks we
need to invest in space and he said I
want humanity to continue being an
energy intensive civilization or to have
an energy intensive civilization so it's
not that we necessarily have to slow
down the goal of equity and fairness
does not have to go with whoa you know
we have to have fewer people we have to
have yeah you know you can have tens of
billions right yeah the issue is like if
we said okay we have a bunch of
conditions to satisfy you know and some
countries are doing a better job of it
than others you know you look at for
example how China has brought way more
people into you know every says although
you know the world has you know gotten
wealthier I go that's a lot you know
it's not the result of market capitalism
you know girl it's also a bunch of very
aggressive men a very strong
intervention in one very large economy
you know where they have actually done a
lot of very effective planning - and
that planning has been driven by the
goal you know they're they're afraid
that if they don't make a better life
for their people they're screwed you
know so they have been on a quest for
how do we make this better for for
people and we kind of look down on you
know a lot about China from our you know
well our great system
you know and our system has lost the
plot
you know it was the land of opportunity
for people and it's no longer DNA of
America and I think that the issue so I
guess the issue is less slowing down and
more like are we satisfying the goals of
our best selves to basically lift
everybody up
and let's not say Oh everybody should be
equal and get the same outcome so delete
old but there has to be opportunity and
there has to be you know III really like
Anand Garrard artist his book winners
take all where he and the basic message
that he has I mean he's it create a lot
of waves with it and maybe sometimes Oh
being a little over-aggressive but this
fundamental idea it's like it's not
enough to say well we have this great
system that's made us really rich and I
will give something back he's like no do
less harm you know yeah you know it's
like and and so that one of the
fundamental market failures in our
current system is that we have a whole
bunch of externalities that we never
take into account which is why I keep
coming back to this ability of
algorithmic you know big data AI systems
to take more factors into account yeah
because our current system you know
again maybe if we had a true market
economy as opposed to one where you know
market power means that the people who
are in power get you know keep giving
themselves more and more of the pie if
we had a system where we were really
saying no we really are trying to take
into account as many factors as possible
to get the right answer we begun oh you
know homelessness clearly a problem oh
well what are some of the problems we're
not building enough houses why are we
not building up houses because the
people who already have them and have
the the money don't want more houses can
give you some ideas yeah yeah let's give
us ideas okay well here's some ideas to
the code okay okay
because the notion that we're moving too
fast is simultaneously potentially true
it needs to be paired maybe with a
little bit of that we're not moving fast
enough and other
yeah sure sure so we saw a lob sighted
okay yes market design so we may we may
if we take the time to slow down connect
to our hearts connect to other humans
connect to earth connect to the unity
that we are here so blessed I have a
hundred billion humans build the
civilization before us and slow down to
that mentality and be with that then
pick up on the areas that need more
acceleration potentially rewrite some of
the code that needs to be autumn nted to
be more of that unity mindset let's say
that kind of stuff I want to give you
these examples let's hear what Tim
O'Reilly's thoughts are about these
examples okay we have people like
Lorenzo de Medici from 1500s and
Florence that patron Michelangelo da
Vinci and enabled the Renaissance of art
to occur we have things like conspicuous
consumption that's roaring out of
control where people are purchasing
status symbols of diamonds and Ferraris
and 7th houses and yachts and jets and
everything because conspicuous
consumption culture has become out of
control and the the notion that the
social fabric isn't able to correct
itself on taina to understand that me
becoming like Medici and actually going
and patronage instead of buying the
seventh house that I can go and give 10
20 50 entrepreneurs and artists a
thousand bucks a month for them to
unleash their creative flourishing more
we haven't changed the culture fully to
that well I guess I like well my thought
on that was first of all Lorenzo de
Medici did a lot of harm you know in
accumulating his power and yes he was
patron of wonderful arts a in fact you
look at all I mean you have to have both
of these perspectives and and we kind of
have to equalize all of the works worlds
sort of great works of art were funded
through inequality
so there's something about inequality
that clearly you know has create creates
things of lasting value it's when it
gets too much right and it's also not
just too much when it's I guess the
thing that I would say is I don't I I
think the real opportunity before us is
not to have lots and lots of people
become patrons I think the opportunity
before us is to do without money that's
the real endgame is this a
decentralization is really it really is
you know can we find other ways to
manage markets that are looking to
optimize human flourishing and there's a
lot of sort of hacks that are bit-by-bit
getting us there it'll straighten some
model for us well well okay let's talk
about the caring economy right now you
know there is an argument to be made
that many innovations actually start
with rich people at hal varian likes to
say if you want to see the future just
look at what rich people do today if in
fact technology is making us richer this
is this is not to take away from my
fundamental deep passionate belief that
we have a deep flaw in our algorithms
for allocation of who gets one why and
we need to improve them but we are
basically creating the future for rich
people what are the rich people have
they have their kids are in school with
you have very small class sizes they
have super good health care right they
have you know the ability to enjoy the
good things of life they have you know
potentially lots of leisure they they
now have things like when they have a
kid and they have a job they get you
know super extended you know parental
leave oh wait you know we're effectively
for rich people we're funding the caring
economy right you know the company goes
oh yeah sure you know Mark Zuckerberg
you know your CEO
but you can you can take three months
off time to content that's right and so
the question is how do we bring that
down so everyone gets the stuff that the
rich people get okay and that's how do
we well I think it's like the baseline
keeps going okay Fuli was the author of
AI superpowers has a great riff in his
book about this and it's a version of
the robot Tax idea mm-hmm it's like you
know and I kind of say let the machines
do all the work you know like great you
know what humans do the human things you
know spending time I mean you and I are
doing this you know this thing we're
having this conversation that's a human
thing machines can't take that right you
know I couldn't give you a robot to have
this conversation with you on my behalf
no yeah well at that point they're
people and here that's a hope that's a
hope that's a whole other thing but yeah
this all you know caretaking education
all these wonderful things that we all
enjoy in the precious to us we need more
time for and how do we make that
available to everyone but anyway his
idea of the of the he calls it a social
investment stipend he says yeah you tax
the robots you know yes automate away
everything and then you tax the robots
and use it to fund human centered
activities you know and you do it
through hacks like saying oh yeah we
have this generous childcare program oh
we have this generous elder care program
oh we actually give people you know a
stipend when they they do community work
let's like we're nonprofit how does the
tax on robot work become implemented
into human oh well I again it's at some
point some country will put into place a
policy like this is not like yeah you
look what happened we didn't used to
have an income tax and then we did we
didn't used to have social security and
then we did I'm just talking about the
u.s. here we didn't used to have
Medicare and then we did somebody
basically says oh here's a revenue
source that we will use to fund this
yeah redistribution it's a market design
issue again you know the tax system is
the prime
a sort of operating system in many ways
of a society so then that's not it is
how as a basic income though that is no
I think I think the basic income I mean
there's a lot about it but no I I think
that there's a there's certainly it's
it's an attractive idea but I'm not sure
it's right you it seems like a band-aid
in some yeah it seems like a badly I do
think that the way we're more likely to
get there I mean because we do there's a
lot that really works about the market
economy how does the robot tax not quite
like that
well so how do you use it if you
basically you know you say okay we're
gonna we're gonna automate things and
then we're gonna tax the robots and then
we're gonna use it for basic basic
income you know maybe we don't get there
you know I think that there is something
that says we want to use again a lot of
what we've taxed ourselves for in the
past are things that are around this
human fabric you know education you know
I mean it's one of the the really hard
part but you know heartening stories
that I kind of go back and bring in
history and books you know why did we
get universal primary education in
America University Universal high school
you know it was actually through people
going wow we needed to tax ourselves so
our kids will have a better future and I
love Bob Putnam they've got the author
of Bowling Alone other books who said in
this meeting I was in once he said you
said all the advances in our society
have come when we have taxed ourselves
to to help other people's children hmm
and I think that that willingness to say
we're gonna give something up in order
to make a fairer society and we're gonna
write rules for our economy for our
algorithmic systems we're gonna write
rules where the fundamental outcome we
are looking for is human flourishing
mmm-hmm and here are things that are
currently underserved and I guess I
would just say that I think that that
you know I foresee a future and this is
where I kind of come back
just by analogy to this these two
markets that make up Google the market
without money and the market with money
and you can imagine a robot world with
money where the robots are transacting
around money and that they're supporting
a human world without money and in the
same way that Google search is like hey
you really want you don't want the thing
that somebody's trying to sell you you
want the thing that that you know we've
been able to determine is the thing I'm
really looking for the best answer you
know the thing that's really going to
delight me and and so we have this
beginning of this sort of hint at this
you know kind of star tech Star Trek
future or you know
yeah banks culture novels whether it's
just like people are supported by the
machines in human activity with the high
tax that enables the caring economy yes
that's right that's right that
effectively you tax the the machines we
are sorry really that you tax the
machines the machines are just doing the
work with just right code
this is I think we can I think we can
get there we'll get there you know
mostly things get there through hacks
although periodically there's a chance
to rewrite the code more profoundly you
know you saw that with the American
Revolution you saw that with you know
the the New Deal you saw that with you
know you know the Great Society you know
I I don't know I think we've law right
now in China in a very profound way
there where they're writing a whole new
set of rules and I do think that there's
a good argument to be made that for all
the things that they're going to get
wrong you know China is way more further
ahead of us in saying how do we use all
of the gifts of technology to build a
society that takes the best of
capitalism but also recognizes that if
we don't create an opportunity for our
people
we're screwed and and you know they they
move faster than we have on things like
climate change you know just all these
things that if you had predicted that
you know
you know 20 years ago you would you you
know yeah it would have been a real
profit this all this conversation about
how to best update civilizations code
moving forward why it's up to us yeah
and figuring out you know who's gonna
own what why yeah and could it
potentially be a way to make the code
work yeah we're all 8 billion of us to
understand the more that we invest into
raising the baseline the more there will
be creative flourishing the more than
you'll be overall that's right there's a
word I wanna I want to pick out of what
you said
who's gonna own what yeah because that's
why I love Al Ross title it's like who
gets what and why and his study was of
markets without money you don't and and
and this really comes up I was thinking
about this because of a wonderful essay
that Sam lesson just wrote in the
information I've heard familiar that
publication but he wrote about the idea
of people owning their data and he was
like worry about what you ask for
because you're taking a concept from a
world where of exclusive exclusivity you
know if I give you this thing I no
longer have it totally it whereas with
ideas I give it to you we both have it
the value there's different rules you
know if everybody has it becomes value
of us at some not depending on baby
there's different rules for things and
for these ideas in this creative economy
and so on and so the question really as
it may not have to do with ownership
ownership may not be the point if we
live in a world who gets one right and
why yeah if we live in a world where you
know it's much more round experiences
for example you know it's like hey what
experiences do you have access to do you
have access to a myriad of experiences
that everybody else has access to and
then you get to pick which ones you want
to do and can we democratize experiences
to that degree
could that be the new baseline for
everyone around the world I think one of
the things that I see in looking at
technology is first of all we're very
very bad at imagining the future when we
talk about a future like this we start
out by framing it you know like we have
these big blinders and it so the the
market stuff money economy yeah yeah
we're just gonna tweak a little bit I
use an example you know in my book and
some of my talks of the you know talked
quite a bit about the evolution of the
the rideshare this is so important and
the evolution of the ride-sharing market
right you know you think about first off
somebody saw it so Neil Paul filed a
patent in 2000 right you know so that
covered most of what later became over
and lifted all the like yeah but if you
know even though in 2000 like 2005
outcome or so outcome the first you know
internet enabled taxicabs what do they
have they've a little screen in the back
showing ads and a credit card reader
that was your internet-connected taxi
cab you know and then even then then
taxi magic comes along in 2007 and
they're kind of trying to work within
the confines of the taxi industry you
know and the taxi it didn't really work
is that the taxi drivers would go well
[ __ ] you know I
yeah I got this web call to go to
somebody's house but he is a passenger
right here I'll pick up now yeah you
know all these the incentives were all
wrong and bit by bit the model evolved
all the more pieces got thrown on the
table there were smart phones in the GPS
you know people invented little bits of
of the answer and then that model
evolved and I think we're in that same
process of of kind of groping our way
towards a future that could be very very
different and the three things I think
about when I when people say you know
this was you know I wrote my book in the
period when everybody's like oh the
robots are gonna take all the jobs and
and I had three answers I said one
there's so much [ __ ] to do that we're
not getting to that we need all the help
from robots that we can get you know and
a good example of that in
you know in the work we do at Code for
America was for example automatic
records clearance you know everyone's
like well we can't really do that it's
too expensive you know this is like for
people who like okay you used to have a
marijuana conviction we just made
marijuana legal can we get it off your
record
well no it's too expensive you know you
have to apply you have to get a lawyer
you know it's trying to pawn the costs
off on on the on the person who was is
suffering instead you know but we're
like hey we can just write a robot you
know a software program that can
download all the records look at them
evaluate them and say these are the
people who are eligible here's the
paperwork you know we could even get rid
of that paperwork if we had a little bit
more integration you know it's like
here's a robot doing a job that was not
getting done yes yeah I think oh there's
so many things like that yeah you know
and so you know could we use robots to
actually make life better cheaper yes
just researching the bottom half of the
of you know 50 year old truck drivers
that's right yeah to do that is right
and then the second thing of course is
is you know this whole caring economy
question it's like if we could figure
out a way for people to be rewarded for
doing things that are human you know
again social fabric tears yeah all those
things that are getting rewarded what
were that yeah I meant hearing your car
and then of course the creative economy
you know where we are doing things for
each other more and more that we we if
we have the leisure time what do we you
know we do with it so this there's all
these reasons why I think we have a lot
of pieces where we could imagine an
economy that's built on very different
lines and I think if I bit people are
working their way towards it and this is
why this whole notion of running the
simulation we're running the updates and
code what does it look like when you
press play when you run the updates and
code could the creative and the caring
economies figure out a way to work with
some sort of an incentive system to get
people to want to actually go in
transition how would the robotic tax
interplay with yeah
it's I mean it's a mix of you know
partners it's already happening you know
just think about it for a minute
we already have this huge attention
economy with it people are working at in
some sense right yeah Google you're
right you're the web which Google then
aggregated here with the search end
people creating this content and yes
there's a market economy for that where
people are saying hey I'm gonna I'm
gonna be able to monetize this via ads
but this huge amounts of content we're
just like produced because people are
creative you know people putting things
on YouTube you know because they love to
create they love to share and then you
know again you overlay the market
economy that gets more good Facebook
people I mean how many hours would it
take to create Facebook I mean that's a
massive amount of human labor right but
it's turned into play and so we already
are building a lot of a very different
economy on which people spend their time
and you know we just haven't really
caught up with with it in in the way we
think and we also haven't caught up with
it in the way that we
yeah we incent businesses because we're
still you know like if you said the job
you know like if you think about if
Facebook were there to optimize human
flourishing let's think about how the
code would yeah well one of the things
that would be missing was they would not
be subject to the master algorithm as I
describe it in my book which says you
must always make more money than you
made the year before yeah they should
master because you know you could you
know really well without the market
incentive you know you you know you know
you wouldn't have an ego that's not true
you know people are making obscene
amounts of money today for things that
people were quite motivated by making a
tiny fraction of that before right and
so I guess the idea that so I guess
that's the main thing I would just say
is that is that we've gotten ourselves
way out of scale in the way that we
think about how much people need to be
rewarded and again it's a basic that
Ronnie do you want to wrap we told him
we were only going for an hour yeah
that's fine let's wrap okay yeah but
okay okay then if we're if we're gonna
wrap then I have some questions okay
well let's do that we can wean do the
rest of the questions but it you know my
my fundamental belief is that that we
could be building like a society that we
would really like to live in we have the
capability and the thing that most makes
us go wrong is this idea that the market
must be satisfied and the market pretty
much means stock price keeps going up
and it's just the wrong objective
function it's the wrong objective
function you know like human facing is
the right of Jeff Gillman flourishing is
the right objective and it could you
imagine if
Facebook that said no we're really you
know we want we need you no way I was
said it's like money is like gas in the
car you don't want to run out yeah but
you're not doing a tour of gas stations
if Facebook were able to live by that
philosophy you go yeah yeah we actually
you know we're making billions already
why do we need to make more billions and
remind me no it's way better for us to
make sure that we don't have a massacre
in Myanmar on our platform oh it's way
better for us if people have trust in
their government oh it's way better for
us if people really are getting
engagement and yes we would trade that
off against squeezing more profit out of
this let's think this is for another
episode in just the ways that that would
happen is the pay cuts in half because
the people would be finding more meaning
the less amount of employees the more
amount to focus on switching up the
business model away from the attention
economy there's so many pieces that
would have to be we have to transition
away from the attention economy you can
actually think about a very positive
version of the attention economy sure of
positive version of reducing working
hours you know reducing the incredible
skew between top and bottom and the way
people get paid you know sociality is
great as it's a gala teri and stock
option system but incredibly rotten in
the way that it's skewed so heavily to
the top yeah yeah so the amount of
options of how to execute this for
objective human flourishing or endless
and we got a share more tests yeah yeah
run more tests okay the couple you know
quick questions on the way out in the
you know in the long term perspective
here it seems like the one that owns the
substrate monopolizes the substrate and
get to control the way that we enter and
interplay with the substrate that is one
of the reasons why the Google that is
one of the reasons why the the the $0.10
this is why the reasons why these
organizations want to be the ones that
control the entry point of us into the
world
do you see this as a central well III
think everybody who wants to think about
that she read Tim Lewis book the master
switch which is basically a history of
monopoly in America mostly but you know
he starts out with you know the the yeah
bail system
you know telephony as monopoly you know
movies you know and the cycle where you
have this this path from you know
scrappy entrepreneurial economy often
with with people who are you know
inventing the future which gets
consolidation I can't talk about this in
my book I hadn't read Tim's book at the
time but it's a wonderful historical
view of how the cycle repeats in
industry after industry and I think
there is a place where you do get to a
point where you know a regulated
monopoly may in fact be the right answer
but certainly you get to the point where
you know there are trade-offs that have
to be made where a company that's in a
position of great power that is also
believes that its only objective is to
make more money is a very unstable very
dangerous situation so either companies
have to self-regulate away from that
position or they have to you know
basically the people need to step up and
regulate the the problem of course is
that you know we have a fairly
dysfunctional government that doesn't
really you know on both right and left
that is kind of dogmatic about this and
not scientific about this question of
how are we you know going to achieve
these best results yeah yeah this
question is I think again a very long so
many options about how to best run code
to questions shows called simulation
easy is a simulation you know I guess I
would say if it is it shouldn't really
matter to us because it's convincing
enough that we have to act as if it's
real
and I guess I've always believed that
you know our our agency you know even if
it's a fiction is the most important
thing we have
and how to maximize flourishing with
that agency across that's my world yeah
yeah and last question is what's the
most beautiful thing in the world you
know if I have to what came into my head
was there's a particular age when your
baby is old enough to put its arms
around your neck you know they can
actually and they yeah still like this
visceral memory of my two daughters an
age sort of maybe year and change where
they they are like still totally in this
blissed-out that it can be and this
blissed-out like total trust of you
space and they put their arms around you
and there's nothing like it in this
world yeah
very beautiful Tim whoo what a crazy Lee
wide-ranging episode that has left me in
in a bunch of different new areas of
thinking and I hope that for those that
have been watching likewise hopefully
hopefully we can continue thinking about
how to best update the code and continue
running these experiments rising
flourishing Tim Riley all right thank
you very much thank you so much for
coming out of the show
honor and pleasure I would love for
everyone watching to give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you about the things that
we talked about you start having these
conversations more in your communities
with your friends your families online
really start thinking about how to
maximize human flourishing what is the
way that we want to write the code check
out Tim's book what's the future and why
it's up to us links in the bio also
check out Oh Riley media check out the
platform it's got so much great
educational information and resources on
it it also has so many conference
listings on it
the amount of conferences you guys do is
just mind-blowing how you guys do that
check all that out below follow tim on
twitter follow him on mediums got so
many great posts there and support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in all our links are below we
would love for you guys to join and
support us we can continue impacting
more people around the world huge shout
out to Ron Vargas our producer and
director thank you very much we
appreciate you greatly and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you so much and
we will see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]